The answer is this.
It is equal to the square root of the sum of the deviations in the y's
over the deviations of the x's.
Note that this is exactly the same as the standard deviation of y
divided by the standard deviation of x,
because the number of observations divides out.
To see that this is, in fact, true, when we divide b/r we can see the numerators cancel,
so we have b/r equal to the square root of the squared differences in the y's
times the sums of the square differences in the x's
over the sums of the square differences in the x's.
The key thing to recognize is we can break this into two pieces.
The denominator can be written as the square of the square root.
Now we can just cancel this and we have our answer.